okay thank you all for coming back uh
let's start up again also for those of
you on um zoom um i'm now actually on
that call as well and so i will be able
to see the questions coming in there i'm
sorry that i didn't track that in the
first half
thanks um okay uh
so before uh
continuing as planned i want to
go back and correct two things from the
previous uh
section so first uh i claimed that
the interventional distribution uh
the effect of intervening on x on
the variable y is identifiable in this
graph
and my claim was correct my derivation
was not
so here is a correct derivation it's
messy it's brief uh but
i believe it is correct uh
so
i don't want to spend too much time on
it but
quickly so i'll start by writing the
joint distribution over y and z given x
as
uh
the following so this is just using the
decomposition that i get in the
interventional graph
where i've eliminated this edge
and marginalizing out u
and now i want to marginalize out z as
well since i'm only interested in the
effect on y
so i just add the summation over z
and now i'm going to introduce uh
a summation over x prime some other
value of x so
some overall
assignments to
x uh so this is different than the fixed
assignment to x that i'm trying to
compute for the intervention and i'm
going to add in a term
for the probability of x prime given u
and this summation i can do because
summing over all x prime here the sum is
just one
and then i'm going to add in
um
to
a numerator and a denominator of what
will become a fraction a term
corresponding to z
given x prime
here's the probability of z given x
prime
so i'm just
adding in the term that i need to be
able to recover the joint distribution
in the numerator here
and
after summing over x prime
or sorry after
summing over u i get that this is equal
to um
the sum over z of p of z given x
times a term that's the sum over x prime
of
uh
is that
what i want okay
um
so
as long as you're convinced that each of
these steps is correct then you should
be convinced that this
is a correct expression for
uh
the interventional distribution on y
given
uh
x or sorry
the distribution
or the effect of intervening on x on y
um
hopefully this example illustrates that
this is in fact quite
uh tricky to get right
and we want a theory that will allow us
to do this in a systematic way
um sorry again about the incorrect
derivation
uh the other thing i want to just
mention again before diving in is
this is the link for the handout uh so
this will contain
pretty much everything i'm gonna talk
about and uh is a useful reference for
definitions that you might not have
caught or just want to remind yourself
of
at any point
um okay
yeah
feel free to
decide to move on but um i'm still
like confused uh about the question that
was asked
um
i guess first about this why
i can't have the identity map like this
sorry do you mind saying that
again please yes so so here's
so that was the other thing i
wanted to address
um
[Music]
so the question was if
this was the identity map then doesn't
this model
uh just devol or degenerate into the
other model which i said was
unidentifiable and the answer i said was
no
and that's true well sorry
here
the issue is i need
the distribution to be positive
in order to be identifiable that is it
needs to have full support
and so
if this was the identity map then it
would not be positive which in
particular would mean i couldn't
um
write this term
depending on or
this term would be zero and so i
couldn't do this manipulation
and so it would not in fact be
identifiable
so i actually need a positive
distribution which forces this to not be
the identity map
um so the result does not hold
if this was the identity map because it
would in fact degenerate into the other
model which is
not identifiable so as a follow-up
question when we talk about like
it's some
interventional distribution is
uh identifiable or whatever the word we
use when we show that decomposed into
observable quantity
do we have a little
asterisk that says like
we assume that the
like that these have a
density that's not zero anywhere like
are we
are we making assumptions like that
um i think we mostly are
i will try to be explicit about where we
are but
if
i don't say anything assume yes
that's definitely safer
okay
so that was all i wanted to say
correcting errors from last time
uh and now i will continue with the
slideshow
the presentation as planned
um
okay so
last time we had
uh introduced bayesian networks and
started to prove some basic results
about distributions that are compatible
with graphs
now we're gonna do a more thorough going
uh characterization of
uh the independencies that are induced
by a bayesian network
um
and we'll need a couple more definitions
um so let's just motivate this with an
example
so let's say we have this
graph and a distribution compatible with
this graph
what conditional independencies hold
for any distribution compatible with
this graph
so
what about this are a and f
conditionally independent given c and e
in this graph yes
so yes
what about
b and g
given f
so yes
yes
what about b and f given e
so yeah it turns out that this is not
the case
um
and
by the end of this hour i'll have
i think hopefully completed proving this
to you
but uh
it's a little bit subtle um
that's the main point i want you to come
away with is that it's not
you shouldn't just think about it hard
and try to
determine it there's a you have to be
systematic about it and uh
we're going to talk about a systematic
way of characterizing all conditional
independencies
uh
that
result in any distribution compatible
with a graph
so we're going to want another piece of
notation
so we'll use this i sub prob
for the
collection of conditional independencies
satisfied
by a distribution p
and
whenever i have a conditional
independence statement here
it's assumed that all the
sets of variables that are appearing are
disjoint
and
i make no claims about anything where
they're not destroying
um yes well one more question is we're
we're now working with um
division
networks and so there's no unobserved
every variable is is written down here
yes great thanks so you can imagine
uh
if we
you can imagine this
uh daisy network comes from some causal
model and that this is unobserved
but and we can still reason about
conditional independencies
um and that's in fact
the power of these of this
representation is we can reason about
conditional independencies without
having access to all parts of the
distribution
as long as we know where
the edges are
okay
so
uh
the first thing we're going to need is
the notion of a blocked trail
so remember a trail is a
sequence of distinct vertices in a graph
or in a dag
where each pair of adjacent vertices
is connected by some edge and the
orientation doesn't matter
so a trail is said to be blocked by a
set z
if it contains three consecutive
vertices such that
they
constitute a chain that is
uh so i apologize
these this a b and c does not refer to
this graph but if we have three vertices
where a points to b b points to c
or a fork
so that is a b that points to a and b
that points to c in this trail
and b
is in the set z
um
so alternatively a trail is blocked
if
it contains
three vertices that form a collider that
is
a points to b c points to b
and
no descendant
of
b
is in the set z
so let's practice with a couple examples
so does
the
set b
lock
this trail
yes so this is just
the first clause this is a fork b is in
the set z
it even has the same name as in the
clause
so yes
okay what about this does e block
the bef
trail
yes so again the first clause
does the empty set block
the bec trail
yes no descendant of e is in
the empty set so yes
okay what about this does e block the b
to e to c to f trail
um
no
right
so
sorry this
this edge is incorrectly uh
this edge should be swapped
but
if you look at the trail in this graph
we start off with b to e to c which is a
collider
e is in
z so this clause does not apply
and then the next
three consecutive vertices are e to c to
f
this is a fork
and c is not in z
so it is not blocked
i apologize this
well
that's just a wall i shouldn't write on
it
anyway um
okay does g block b to e to c and here
i've of course drawn the arrow in the
correct direction
uh
no
right so here
we again have a collider and g
is a descendant of e
so this condition is not met so this
trail is not blocked
so you might be concerned about the
double negatives everywhere
we are going to have notation for a not
blocked trail in a second i know
um but the reason we care about blocked
trails is
because they are used to define d
separation which will be extremely
important
as follows so
let's say we have
disjoint sets x y and z
we'll say that x is d separated from y
by z if every trail between any vertex
and x
and any vertex
in y
is blocked
and in that case we write
x
is d separated from y by z in g
so this notation is
remarkably similar to that for
conditional independence and that's not
coincidental
and this is again why it's important to
keep track of the subscript so we use a
subscript g for graph
for the d separation concept and we use
the subscript p for the probability
concept
and
if
there is a trail from x to y that is not
blocked
by z then we say that x and y are
deconnected given z or d connected by z
and we'll call a trail that's not
blocked an active trail
okay so
with that said let's take a look at this
example again
and try to figure out what d separations
hold in g
so are a and f
d separated by c and e
in g
can you give us again the definition of
this operation my bullets yeah
well i'll give you a this will be a
spoiler but it turns out deseparation
will correspond exactly to conditional
independence in a sense that i'll make
precise
uh
so
you can just think of it as conditional
independence and you'll get most of
these answers right if you're
comfortable with conditional
independence um
but again the definition of
de-separation
uh
well
i'll just
return back
to this slide
so a d separation is
any trail between
any vertex and x and any vertex and y is
blocked
and blocked means
any chain or if means there's a chain
with the middle vertex
in in z or a fork with the middle vertex
in z
or
there's a collider
and no descendant of
the middle vertex is in z this is not an
intuitive definition it's
we're going to spend a lot of time
working with it and hopefully it'll
become
easier over time but uh
yeah let's
look at this example and
we'll see if we can get the hang of it a
bit
so
here
to check whether a and f are d separated
given c and e we have to ask is every
path
between a and f blocked by c and e
sorry every trail between a and f
blocked by c e
so let's first look at uh
this trail a b e f is this blocked by c
and e
yes because this b e f segment is a
chain and e is in the conditioning set z
let's look at the other trail a b e c
f
is this blocked
yes so this one is not blocked at this
collider because e
is in the conditioning set but it is
blocked at this fork because c is in the
conditioning set
okay
so
is b and g
d are b and g d separated by f
so let's look at all trails between
b and g
so there's a
b e f g trail that's blocked by f
there's a b e c f g trill
and that's blocked
by f again because
no matter whether we go we end the trail
with e f g or c f g we have a chain
and f is blocked in the chain sorry f is
in the conditioning set so that chain is
blocked
what about uh
b and f
given e
no so this is the same example as before
i think uh
right so
the following trail
is active not blocked between b
and f
uh conditioned on e the trail b e c f
because the b e c collider
is not blocked because we condition on e
and the e c f chain is not blocked
because we haven't conditioned on c
so
this is a case where conditioning on e
blocks one of the trails
that connects b to f but it doesn't
block the other trail and in fact it
activates the other trail
right if we hadn't conditioned on e
and we were just looking at whether b
and f were d separated given the empty
set
they they would not be they would be
connected given the empty set because
bef would be
available but conditioning on e
blocks this trail
but then activates this trail
so it's a subtle concept
we'll get a lot of practice reasoning
about it but are there any questions
about the definition
yes
i don't want to take up too much time on
it but i have another question about the
example
that we started with
on the left
which
i may want to ask and feel free to
ignore it and talk about afterwards but
it's blocking me a little bit because um
i think that
the way that i understood the causal
like
diagrams
uh was that there was or the causal like
the
tuple that we had was that z is a
function of x
and if it wasn't a function of x as a
function of some other kind of u
i'd have a little dash arrow
to it
and if it's a function of x i don't
understand how
we can possibly have you know the
probability of x y z is bigger than zero
for all
possible xyz because now i must be
misunderstanding such so i think this is
actually a point
worth clarifying so we're going to jump
back to beginning but this is kind of
important
so the question is
at the beginning of this
uh segment i mentioned that this can
can't be the identity map
in order for this to be identifiable
but if z is just a function of x then
um
how is it not
then where does
and these are both you know binary
random variables and
well how do i get a positive
distribution here and the answer is
wherever you have
uh
basically there are
u's
background random variables that only
talk to one variable that are just not
drawn
so you should imagine
that x
gets its own little private source of
randomness
and z gets its own little private source
of randomness
yes sorry
private uh ux
uy
and
anywhere
on the graph where you have an
observable variable there's an
additional source of randomness that can
be used
to prevent
each variable from being a deterministic
function
of
uh
to prevent z from being a deterministic
function of x
writing down the ones
that
you know uh deal with two or more yes
i'm not writing down but i guess i
really can't deal with like i really
can't deal with zed is a function of of
things
i really can't do that yeah so assume
everything's positive for the time being
and you'll be safe uh things fall apart
if your distributions are
are degenerate in the way that you're
concerned okay
sorry so
let's
jump back to where we were d separation
so
um
we've done a couple examples
would not be surprised if you're still
not entirely comfortable with it but uh
we'll get more practice um
yeah so
i think i already went through this so b
and f
are not d separated by e because the b e
c f trail is active even though the b e
f trail is blocked
so to be de-separated all trails
between
your start and then or between
your uh two quantities need to be
blocked
by the set z
um
and we're going to
use notation
that is uh remarkably similar to that
for probability
uh for the set of all
d separations that hold in a given graph
and
um
the reason we care about d separation is
that
it
gives us the answer we were looking for
to what conditional independencies are
implied by a graph
so
here's a theorem
if x and y are d separated by z
in a graph g
then
x and y are conditionally independent
given z
in all distributions p that are
compatible with that graph
so deseparation
tells you that
a conditional tells you that the
corresponding conditional independence
exists for every distribution that's
compatible with the graph
so here's a question is the
converse true
where well
i i have to be clear about where i'm
well
here's
what the other direction looks like
so if
x and y are not d separated
by z
then there's some distribution p
that's compatible with the graph in
which
x and y are not conditionally
independent
so
of course
i could
find a distribution p compatible with
the graph in which
x and y are independent
because
if i just have a distribution p that's
created by just independently choosing
every observable variable
then all conditional independencies hold
whether or not
and this distribution is compatible with
every graph
so the best we can do is say is to say
that
whenever we don't have a d separation
then we can find some distribution that
witnesses
conditional dependence between the
variables that are not de-separated
given the conditioning set
so is that statement clear
okay so we're not going to prove this
right now but i think we will by the end
of
this session um
but we're going to start with
a slightly easier question and this is
mostly a tactical decision to defer this
because
this is more involved
than what we're going to look at right
now
the question we're going to address
right now is
which graphs have the same d separations
and then because of the the theorem
which we'll prove later this is the same
thing as asking which graphs
imply the same
conditional independences
so here's the characterization which
we'll prove
um and so
we call two graphs
uh or we'll say that two graphs with the
same d separations are in the same
markov equivalence class
that's where the the name of the slide
and the name of this theorem comes from
but i i won't use this this terminology
very much
uh but here's the characterization so
we'll say that g1 and g2 have the same
d sub the theorems as g1 and g2 have the
same d separations
if and only if
they have the same skeleton and the same
immoralities
to be defined in a second but the first
thing to make clear is i haven't written
them out but g1 and g2 need to be
defined on the same vertex set right
they have to have some common vertex set
otherwise
this won't even make sense
so
what is the skeleton of a graph
it's just the undirected graph you get
when you erase all the arrowheads from
the edges right so
this is the graph g
the skeleton of the graph is just the
undirected underlying graph
what are immoralities
an immorality is a collider so again a
collider
is a segment
of three vertices
where x of the form
x y z where x points to y and z points
to y
or in this case
b e c is a collider
in which so for for a collider to be an
immorality it must be the case
that the outer two vertices are not
adjacent
so
in this graph bec is a collider and b
and c are not adjacent so this is an
immorality
and the claim
for the theorem
is that g1 and g2 have the same d
separations if and only if they have the
same skeleton
and the same immoralities
what's immoral about this
i don't know
yes
parents are not married there we go
that's that's what's important
is that
the origin of the term
okay
is that a question
mathematical question
so adjacent means that b looks at c we
do not look about both directions
so adjacent means that there's either an
edge between b or from b to c or from c
to b adjacent
sorry at least
is there anything that we could see both
of them no so we will not see
so we use shorthand of bi-directed edges
to represent
unobserved confounders
but that is just shorthand
and should not be taken to mean
that
there are edges in both directions
because again we're only working with
acyclic graphs
and uh
if there were edges in both directions
we have a cycle so for our purposes
the true edges and the underlying graph
are always we only either have an edge
from b to p c c to b or neither but
never both
other questions
oh yes
what's justin says example what one
arrow you could flip in this graph to
uh
and present the markov equivalent that's
a great question
right there okay
or that one
or that one
so
um
let's let me go back
so sorry for those listening in the
question was what arrows can i flip in
this graph and preserve the markov
equivalents preserve the d separations
for mean and the same markov equivalence
class those are two ways of saying the
same thing so i could flip this arrow
the a to b arrow
because i haven't introduced an
immorality and of course if i'm flipping
arrows i'm preserving the same skeleton
there's still no collider here there
wasn't a collider there before so i'm
not introducing the immorality
here
if i flip the b to d edge i'm still not
introducing a collider
if i flip
the
c to f edge i'm also not introducing or
sorry i uh
yeah i am not introducing a collider
um get rid of a collider
yes so
there was a collider
here
but it's not an immorality because c
there's the cte
edge
and so
i'm allowed to manipulate that collector
and in particular i can flip the seed at
that
that's cyclic isn't it
yeah yes
sorry
i can flip the seed
thank you
so that would not be allowed because
i've introduced a cycle
i could have flipped uh
the c to e uh i could not flip the c to
e edge because
i would then
change the immoralities right because b
c is an immorality
what could i do
um
um
[Music]
oh
yeah
yeah okay
okay
thank you for catching that i
will interpret that as
uh evidence that you're paying attention
um okay just to be sure uh
can we invest f2e yes or no uh yeah so
we cannot flip the fte edge
because even though it doesn't introduce
a collider
between e f and g it does it would
introduce a collider
f
to e
to b
and that collider would be an immorality
so the resulting graph would have an
immorality that's not present in the
current
okay so we're going to prove this
theorem
and in order to do this we need
a preliminary lemma which is
uh
almost obvious but not quite
so
um
here's the statement
if two vertices are not adjacent in a
graph
then they are conditionally independent
sorry they're be separated
in the graph given
both of their parents
so when i am indexing variables by uh
irj i'll just write
parents of i or parents of j just to
save
symbols
um so how can we prove this
um
so
uh
how do we prove this um
well we're gonna do it
as follows
um
okay so let's say we have
x i and xj
and we're conditioning on their parents
so i'll just kind of draw that like this
for conditioning on xi's parents
and we're conditioning on xj's parents
um we need to argue that there are no
active trails between the two of them
or another way of saying that is that
any trail between the two of them is
blocked
so
they're not adjacent so there's no edge
from x side xj
um
so
how could we
build a trail between the two of them
well we can't
have any trail that uses either of their
parents
because either
any such trail would be blocked by
conditioning on their parents
um so let's just assume for the sake of
contradiction that we do have a trail
connecting the two of them
um
so
this edge cannot be oriented this way
v1 cannot be apparent of x i because
then
this segment
right here would either be a chain or a
fork
with v1 in the conditioning set so it
would be blocked
by the same reasoning
this segment here
can't be
uh a chain or a fork
and so vk cannot have an edge into xj
because then this triple here would be
blocked
so we know
that
if there is indeed an active trail
uh as we assumed was a contradiction
um
sorry then uh
the edges
uh from xj
there must be an edge from xj to the
vertex immediately preceding it
and there must be an edge
from x i
to the vertex v1
okay
and
now if that's the case there must be a
collider somewhere in the trail
right we have one edge pointing this way
another edge pointing this way at some
point in the trail we must switch from
pointing this way
two that way so there has to be a
collider
okay so let
w
be the first collider that we run into
as we're walking
from x i
this way
so another way of writing this is
using my squiggle notation which looks
great on
in latex but i can't draw it at all
right so there's a directed path from x
to w
the first collider that we encounter
um
and let y be the first collider that we
encounter going in the other direction
yeah sorry
i wrote x here what i mean is x i here i
mean xj
and here's y
um so
if there's only a single collider on the
trail
then w equals y
and now for the trail to be active this
collider
has to have some
descendant in the conditioning set but
the conditioning set
is just the parents of i and the parents
of j
and so
any descendant of
let's say w in the case for w equals y
has to be either a parent of i or a
parent of j
and in either case let's say we have a
descendant here that is a parent
uh
of
i well then we have a contradiction
right a parent of i can't be
uh can't appear as a descendant of i
that would be a cycle
and neither can we have w
having a descendant that's a parent of j
um because then if w equals y
right then we have a path
here from
xj to a parent of j which is also a
contradiction
so that can happen
so the only case left is where w does
not equal y
and
here it's allowed for x i
to have a descendant
uh which is a parent of j that's fine so
maybe this collider is activated by a
parent of j
this collider is activated by a parent
of i
um
right that's okay
but in that case we have that xj
uh comes before i in the topological
order
they're in any topological order namely
xj has i as a descendant and xi has xj
as a descendant that's a contradiction
we have a cycle
so this can happen and we conclude that
x i and xj have to be deseparated given
our condition on both of their parents
so this may seem like a lot of trouble
to go to
for
a little lemma
but it's going to be worth it because
it will allow us to immediately prove
the following
direction of this markov equivalence
characterization which is that if g1 and
g2 have the same d separations
then they have to have the same skeleton
and immoralities
so why is that
let's look at the following case
so first
what if
they don't have the same skeleton
what if g1 has some edge that's not
present in g2
and in particular let's just say there's
some x
to y edge present in g1 but not in g2
i claim that
then
x and y are deconnected
in g1
conditioned on their parents
and they're d separated in g2 condition
on their parents
and the reason for this is just
by the previous lemma
x and y are definitely d
separated in g2
condition on their appearance
and then we have a direct a trail
in x to y a single edge that
is active
condition on both their parents
in g1 so this contradicts our assumption
that they have the same d separations
um
so it can't be the case that they have
the same d separations but have
different skeletons
so we've ruled that out
what about immoralities
so let's consider the case where
g1 and g2 have
the same skeletons but different
immoralities
and they somehow have the same d
separations
can this happen
so without loss of generality let's say
that g2 has this immorality
and that it's somehow not an immorality
in g1
but because their skeletons are the same
the edges must be present they just must
be reoriented or oriented differently
and now
for this to be an immorality
in g2 it must be the case this
there's no edge from x to y or y to x
that's what it means to be an immorality
it's a collider with where x and y are
not adjacent
so apply the same lemma again condition
on both of their parents
these are d separated
but clearly
conditioning on the same set of vertices
which do not contain all the parents in
uh
of y for example in this picture
we get that x and y are deconnected on
the left
right so if
uh
so this immorality
uh and this can or sorry so in g2
they're de-separated conditioned on the
parents of x and the parents of y
in g1
no matter how we change the edges here
to ensure that this is not an immorality
these are going to be deconnected
because
as long as it's not
the only way for
this to not be an immorality
when this edge is missing is for it to
either be a chain or a fork
um and in either
to either be a chain or a fork and in
either case
this path is going to be active
conditioned on these parents
any
questions about that
so the conclusion is
if g1 g2 have the same d separations
then they have the same skeleton and
moralities
uh yeah so here you can see
no matter how we
uh
get a different
a graph without that immorality on the
left
we're still going to have x and y d
connected condition on the same set
okay
so to prove the converse is going to be
a little bit more difficult so this is
that if they have the same skeleton and
immoralities
then they are
deconnected
uh sorry if they have the same skeleton
and the immoralities then they have the
same d separations
so we need the notion of a tight active
trail
um
and
i'm going to
put this on the board um
so what is a tight active trail
so a tight active trail
so it's going to be an active trail
that's minimal in the following sense so
it's a trail b1
bk
such that
no subsequence
vertices
in the trail
is active
between the same start and end
right so i can't just do a shortcut
where i skip
v2 for example and go v1 v3 all the way
up through vk
and get an active trail
and there should be no no way
to move things down in the following
sense
um
no active trail
um
w1
or wk
such that
um wi
is in the descendants
of vi
so i can't take this active trail and
replace everything with descendants
and
sum
w
i does not equal
vi
so is this definition clear
so a tight active trail it's an active
trail where you can't
replace or you can't just find a
shortcut and skip some vertices and you
can't replace vertices with descendants
and also get an active trail
so first
can you remind us
an active
yeah
trail
an active trail is a trail that is not
blocked
okay great
so an active trail is proof of
deconnection
and
no active trail is proof of
de-separation
i wish i could eliminate it
illuminate it
uh
not particularly
i don't have a great
so this definition is constructed so
that i can
prove this claim uh
it's not
it it won't really be useful in any
other context
so is the idea of a tight active trail
just that whenever xy or d connected
[Music]
there is not actually necessarily a
unique tight active trail
but uh
it's just going to be a kind of
canonical example of a trail or oh it's
it's going to be a kind of trail where i
can easily
reason about what its structure is
and i so here here's the first
observation if they're deconnected there
is a tight active trap
between them so if x and y are
deconnected by z there is a tight active
trail witnessing that connection
so here's the proof
start with any active trail
and repeatedly check can i find a
subsequence of vertices
in this trail that preserves
its it being active if so replace it
with that
then check is there any way to replace
any vertex with the descendant of it it
preserves it being active if so replace
it with that there are only a finite
number of trails
in a finite graph
so eventually i'll run into some trail
that i can't uh
improve in any way and that will be a
tight afterthough
uh
sure um
let's see
so
i'll give you examples of things that
are not tight active trails and
hopefully that'll be
helpful um
so
so here's x and y
um
if my graph looks like this
x to w to y is not a tight active trail
if my conditioning set is empty because
i could just
drop the w vertex and go directly from x
to y
if my trail looks like this
and
uh w2 is my conditioning set
the trail x to w to y is active because
i've conditioned
on w2 so that activates this collider
but this is not a tight active trail
because i can replace w with w2 and
replace the trill with x to w2 to y and
that's also active
so this violates the first condition
this violates the second condition
so
uh
you know okay the x to y is tight in the
first
x w two is
x to w two to y is nine
um so why bother with uh this definition
because
we get the following
so
the lemma is the following so if i have
a tight active trail
relative to some conditioning set z
then
whenever i have
a shortcut
that is
i have
x i minus one
has an edge to x i plus one
[Music]
then it must be the case that
i have a fork
and either x i minus one or x i plus one
is a collider
um
so
i'm looking at the time and realizing
i'm going
slower than i had expected um
so
um
[Music]
i'm going to skip the proof of this
lemma even though
it is the whole reason for having
uh this definition and
i'm going to skip directly to the
application of this llama
and i should mention quickly
if xi is a collider in
t in this tight active trail
then um
it must be an immorality that's a
corollary of this
uh
by the contra positive
um
so how are we going to use this
um so
the proof by the way is in the handout
so please do refer to that
as needed
um
okay so
let's
prove
this uh direction of the claim using
this lemma which i will remind you of
its statement when i use it
so let's fix um g1 and g2 with
the same skeleton and immoralities
and let
t
let t1
be
a tight active trail
between um
uh
the
type
active
trail
between
uh
x and y
conditioned on z
um
and let t2 be the same trail in g2
so we're going to show that this trail
is also active and that will apply the
conclusion
so
let's just pick three vertices along the
trail
and show that that three vertex segment
is also active in g2 if we can do this
for any segment of vertices along the
trail then we're done
so
okay so here's our segment
first observation um
let's consider the case where this is
not a collider in t1
sorry in g1 it's not a collider
um
so then it it also
must not be the case
that
um it must also be the case that
this is not a collider
in
g2
because
if this edge is present
then
my claim is
not being a collider here
in team in g1 implies also not being
quieter in g2
because
otherwise um
no matter
uh
sorry
uh i'm sorry if it's not excuse me
if this edge isn't present then i can't
have a collider in one and not a
collider in the other because that would
be an immorality in one that's not
present that's all i wanted to say
so
um
but what if they are adjacent what if x
i minus one is adjacent to x i plus one
then
we know by this lemma that
black didn't prove that this must be a
fork
so i have to take my word for it and
then that forces one of
uh
uh
that forces
um
one of x i minus one or x i plus one to
be a collider by the second part of this
lemon
and then
it must be an immorality
in g2
so
the reasoning is again as follows
if this edge is present
in
both graphs
but
we have a
um
and so we have a fork here by the lemma
then we have a collider either here or
here
by this lemma
and then that must be an immorality
again by the lemon
and then
that allows us to conclude
that x i is not a collider
i apologize this reasoning is
a lot less clear if you haven't absorbed
the statement of the lemma
um let's move on to the next
more interesting case
so let's consider the case where
this
is
a collider
in g1
okay
so now
by this lemma and its corollary because
this is a tight active trail this is an
immorality so that's kind of the power
of the definition with adaptive active
trails any collider is an immoral
and um
uh okay
and because it's an immorality it's also
present in g2
and now so let's consider some cases so
what if x i is in the conditioning set
um then
the trail segment is also active in g2
um
right if i have
i have the same conditioning set and i
have an immorality
and i condition on the the collider then
it's active in both graphs because the
immorality is preserved
so the only way this could go wrong is
if
in g1 i have some descendant
of x i
that's in the conditioning set but in g2
because i've flipped some edges around
i've lost
the path to a descendant that makes this
active
right so
um
so let's say i have some descendant here
w
that is
in the conditioning set
but somehow it's not in the descendant
of x i in this other graph g2
um
well my claim is going to be that this
um
path here doesn't contain any colliders
in g2
so let's call this s
and suppose that in g2 somehow we ended
up getting a collider here
that we flipped some edges around
and in particular let's say you know we
flipped
something that looked like this to this
into something that looked like this
and we generated the collider
um
then
we must have the
uh
a and so let's call this abc
so this is a zoomed in segment of this
path and i'm looking at it in g2
well because this was a
um
a tight active trail and because g1 and
g2 have the same immoralities
we know that a and c must have been
adjacent in g1
right because otherwise i'd have
introduced an immorality in g2 that
wasn't present
in g1
um and then because of the direction of
the edges right in g1 we had a
to b to c we must have the the missing
edge goes from a to c otherwise we'd
have a cycle
in g1 oh sorry and g2
um
[Music]
okay
and now my claim is
uh
that if i am considering the shortest
directed path
here um so
sorry
back here
my claim or i chose
i didn't spell this out as much as i
should have but
i wanted w to be
the vertex in z
that was reachable by a shortest
directed path
and uh if i chose it that way then i
can't have
this shortcut present right so this
situation can't happen because then i
could find a shorter path where i
skipped from a directly to c
um
okay
so the remaining case
so so
i can rule out the presence of a
collider in g2 along this path
because if that was if that happened i
could find a shortcut in g1
contradicting my choice of the path
so the remaining case the only way that
this could go wrong and deactivate the
path
in g2 is if
the very first edge right out of x i
was flipped between g1 and g2
so let's draw the resulting picture
um
so in g2 we'd have this
um
and let's call this vertex w prime
and uh
sorry
okay
ah yeah okay so we have this picture
um and then since
the colliders um x i minus 1 x i
w prime and w prime x i x i plus 1 are
not present
in g1 by assumption
it must be the case that um
these are not immoralities
because if they were again then they'd
have different immoralities so we must
have that this edge
and this edge are present
in
g in in both of the graphs
um and by acyclicity
right they can't be uh
they have to have this orientation
because in g1
uh the path
goes this way and then down and so we
end up with the following picture
and this exactly contradicts
the claim that our original thing was a
tight active trail because
in g1 we could have
replaced
x i with w prime
so
uh
the conclusion is that there are no
colliders on this
on the trail from x i
to a descendant in z in either graph
g1 or g2
and so
in g2 we have the same picture
and this segment remains active
and we've taken an active path in g1 an
active trail in g1 and found that it's
also active in g2 so these tight active
trails
they are
a subset of trails that are preserved
under these markov equivalence classes
so that's one way of thinking of them
anyway since this was arbitrary we
conclude
that
uh
uh
that the whole trail is at is active
and
then
right so we've taken any active trail in
any tight active trail in t1 and proven
there's a correspond that the exact same
trail is active
in g2 if g2 has the same skeleton and
immoralities
which proves the conclusion
um
okay so
modulo the lemo which i didn't prove
i have now established that
two graphs with the same vertex sets and
the same skeleton and immoralities have
exactly the same d separations
um i think that's time or a little bit
over time and so
after lunch i'll come back and show that
deseparation actually corresponds to
conditional independence and then we'll
move on to the specifically causal stuff
and the due calculus and the id
algorithm
okay thanks
you're on your own for lunch now and we
reconvene at 2.